bonjour ma très chère amie
bonjour de Monsieur du snap 3 ma chère
amie quel ravissement d'admirer une
artiste comme vous vous êtes vraiment
une très grande danseurs
prennent beaucoup pour réussir mon pack
2 avec Casimir
[Musique]
pas de 2 est un ballet avec deux
personnages lorsque vous êtes avec
Casimir vous seul dansez lui il se
traîne oh ben moi je trouve qu'il se
débrouille pas mal du tout il a le sens
du ring c'est pas un grand danseur mais
je vous trouve sévère
quelqu'un quand même moi je serais le
partenaire idéal avec la force de mes
bras vous pourriez vous envoler dans les
heures et
descendre doucement et vous poser au sol
avec grâce ah bon vous savez danser vous
avez appris notre cher ami oubliez-vous
à qui vous parlez mais pas besoin
d'apprendre
Jean de ma qualité on ça dans le sang
est-ce que je pourrais avoir une petite
démonstration mais oui mais très
volontiers étonné ma canne mon chapeau
où puis-je me mettre
là par exemple c'est parfait
qu'est-ce que vous voulez comme musique
est-ce que vous voulez cher ami je peux
danser sur n'importe quelle musique
alors attention
[Musique]
je suis en pleine forme je me suis
seulement arrêté parce que je pensais
que cela suffisait pour vous prouver
l'étendue de mon talent
c'était formidable
enfin Casimir tu commences à avoir du
goût je suis très heureux que cela t'a
plu je n'ai jamais autant ri de ma vie
mais ce serait encore plus drôle si vous
aviez un nez rouge et un petit chapeau
de clown tu n'as pas honte de te moquer
de moi de parler de rire après
l'exhibition que je viens de faire digne
des plus grandes opéras ah ce n'est pas
un numéro comique
pour le penser
ah bon alors c'est beaucoup moins drôle
cher ami que pensez-vous de ces proposes
un joyeux monsieur
et mon partenaire
bon vous ne voulez pas de moi mais
je ne vais pas chasser quasiment
très bien j'ai compris
[Musique]
je
me retiens plus un génie restera
incompris au revoir
monsieur du stop oui
oui pensez quand même à mon idée le nez
rouge et le chapeau de clown je ne
répondrai pas à cette insulte
tu mets les deux pieds bien serrés bien
parallèle les bras le long du corps
point
tu refais la même chose de l'autre côté
point talons plié bien plié
oui
talon plié bien vous regardez chez vous
pour savoir en faire autant de Casimir
bon très bien bah tu as très bien
compris là alors un autre mouvement
explique les bras comme ça les doigts
écartés tiens mets-toi face à moi pour
voir très bien et la crête bien tendue
voilà alors maintenant reviens là
et plier tendu plié tendu plié tendu
plié tendu sur le côté la même chose
pliez tendu plié tendu plié tendu plié
comme si tu donnais un coup de pied
reste bien droit
bien devant côté derrière
on va commencer la danse
alors musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît je suis bien dans le
jardin de l'île aux enfants oui je suis
en train de jouer à chat perché avec eux
justement bonbon bien sûr on dirait
quelque chose mais voilà je suis
journaliste et mon rédacteur en chef m'a
envoyé dans cette île pour faire un
reportage et au port on m'a dit que
c'est dans le jardin que je trouverai
les personnes les plus intéressantes à
interviewer certainement et moi
d'ailleurs je suis prêt à répondre à
toutes vos questions et après si vous le
désirez bien vous interroger les autres
et pour tout vous dire je préférerais
faire mon article sur une seule personne
c'est toujours plus intéressant que
lorsqu'on se disperse en parlant de
beaucoup de gens il faut donc que je
choisisse sans erreur la personne la
plus intéressante du jardin je veux
comprendre tout à fait mais si cette
jeune femme mais c'est Julie attendez
Julie s'il te plaît Julie vient voir
voilà je te présente monsieur qui est
journaliste il aimerait faire un article
sur la news
alors je ne sais pas il me faudrait une
sorte de vedette une vedette était moi
personnellement je suis marchand de
ballons je sais pas si c'est très très
original et moi je vends des caramels
mous et des sucettes géantes c'est très
ordinaire en effet je ne vois là rien de
bien intéressant pour mon article pour
mettre tant pis
je vois monsieur du snobe là-bas il
pourrait peut-être faire votre affaire
c'est une personnalité
c'est le président de la fête annuelle
de l'île aux enfants
mes très chers amis
et que je ne souffre pas qu'en
m'interrompre quand je parle avec des
amis quel est ce personnage
il vient d'arriver sur l'île aux enfants
il aimerait faire un article sur vous
pouvez pas le dire plus tôt enfin mon
ami vous permettez que je vous appelle
mon ami je suis prêt à répondre à toutes
les questions que vous voulez bien me
poser je vous écoute je m'appelle
monsieur Disney je suis le président de
la fête au lieu des enfants oui je ne
parle qu'à des personnalité mais enfin
pour vous je fais une exception vous
savez la fois poète et aussi artiste et
je suis imprécier
c'est notre vedette à nous bonjour tout
le monde
extraordinaire bon vous trouvez vraiment
mais bien sûr mais c'est sur lui qu'il
faut que je fasse mon article monsieur
Casimir c'est moi je voudrais faire un
article sur vous sur moi oui voulez-vous
me suivre quelques secondes et répondre
à quelques petites questions
ainsi je préfère maintenant les je vais
vous poser une petite question je vous
écoute attendez laissez-moi le temps de
la poser
quelle différence y a-t-il entre le
journal quotidien
l'hebdomadaire et le mensuel
c'est facile c'est tellement facile que
je vais aller dire à mes amis que vous
avez
osé me poser une question aussi facile
François
parce que il faut que vous m'aidiez j'en
ai quelques-uns quel est ton problème
les enfants les autres venez venez venir
alors voilà monsieur le journaliste me
demande la différence entre quotidien en
hebdomadaire et un mensuel vous avez
compris la question de Casimir alors un
quotidien c'est un journal qui paraît
tous les combien
tous les jours tous les jours
compris Casimir un hebdomadaire c'est un
journal qui paraît tous les combien
tous les mois
vous êtes vraiment fort
venez avec moi vous allez voir comment
je vais lui répondre s'il se trompe s'il
se trompe vous lui soufflerez d'accord
j'ai voulu que mes amis assistent à ma
réponse les voilà ils sont tous là alors
un quotidien est un journal qui paraît
tous les mois c'est ça
quotidien
tous les jours
mensuel tous les mois voilà alors vous
faites mon article mais oui vous êtes
bien à la vedette numéro 1 de l'île aux
enfants je suis abonné je suis une
vedette bonjour tout le monde voilà le
facteur vous savez la nouvelle et bien
un bébé hippopotame vient de naître
hippopotame c'est bien plus intéressant
mais qui sait vous serez peut-être
vedette une autre fois au revoir
et mon article